So, let's look at what kind of structures and what
do we have in the hardware with the ROB. So,
we still have the instruction queue, from which we dispatch
into the reservation stations. We still have the RAT, that can
point to a register file, or to the rename name
for the instruction until it writes to the register file.
But RAT entries that point to, not to register file
in, in normal Tomasulo's algorithm would point to the reservation stations.
Now, however, we have a new structure called the
reorder buffer, or ROB. It has a head and tail
pointer, and basically the instructions that are currently in
execution are between these two pointers. The head pointer is
the pointer to where we are going to put the
next instruction that issues. The tail pointer is where we
are considering instructions for commit and the RAT entries
that are not pointing register file are now pointing to
the ROB entries for the instructions that are going to produce its value.